وهذه اخبار عاجله تاتي من الحواره مراسل
العربيه يتحدث عن اصابات جراء المواجهات
في بلده حوار بين الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين
اسرائيليين نتابع هذه الصور لهذه
الاشتباكات والمواجهات الحاصله في بلده
حواره بين الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين
اسرائيليين سنتابع الان يبدو بان هذه
الصور ايضا سنعود ونتابعها مجددا نعود
ونذكر بان هناك اصابات جراءه مواجهات بلده
حواره بين الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين
اسرائيليين
وهذه البلده التي واجهت ايضا حصلت فيها
ايضا
مواجهات في الايام الماضيه وايضا كان هناك
تصريح لوزير الاسرائيلي الذي قال بانه يجب
ان يتم محوها وكان هناك ايضا العديد من
المواقف تجاه هذا التصريح بخ بلده حواره
ساذهب الان الى زميلنا خالد القاسم
ليعطينا تفاصيل ما يجري في الحواره خالد
اليك ما الجديد ماذا يجري
يعني اخر الانباء الوارده بان مستوطنا
اطلق الرصاص على مركبه فيها اربعه
فلسطينيين لم يصب الرصافه احد ولكن
الاربعه اصيبوا من تناثر الزجاج
المتكسر
هناك اعتداءات من المستوطنين الان داخل
بلده حواره حيث يقومون براقصات استفزازيه
في شوارع البلده والكون الحجاره على
المركبات الماره ويهددون
السكان
بالطرد والقاتل في هذه الاثناء
ولكن خالد يعني هذه المواجهات ليست جديده
يعني الحواره هي تتصدر المشهد في الايام
الماضيه بخصوص المواجهات بين
المستوطنين والفلسطينيين من بلده حواره
اليس هناك من اي اجراءات متخذه حتى لا
تتكرر هذه المواجهات
يعني
الاجراءات هي التي يجب ان ياخذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لح
مايه
الفلسطينيين المستوطنون يدخلون الى وسط
حواره يقومون برقصات وهم بالعشرات يجيبون
شوارع الرئيسيه للبلده
بمكبرات الصوت والصراخ والمناداه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يتواجد لا يمنحهم
الاحتياطات التي قام بها الفلسطينيون هي
احكام اغلاق النوافذ والابواب خشيه من
تكرار حوادث حرق المنازل كما حدثت
الاسبوع الماضي ايضا يتحصنون ويشكلون لجان
حراسه لتوعيه الناس عندما يقتحم
المستوطنون المدينه على كل حال لخالد نعود
اليك في حال تطورت ايضا الامور التي طلعنا
على اي جديد شكرا لك حتى الان خالد القاسم